hello everybody and welcome back to
Drunk Minecraft Wade quit it I'm not
doing anything and Bob they're diing
around back I have an apple I have an
apple now we are on a Giant floating
island
of coton cotton grass cotton and grass
and or down below wow there's gold and
bookshelves and bookshelves for some
reason oh there you are hi hey guys
how's it going say hi to everyone at
home hi everyone how do how do I wave
what the wave button there is no wave
button you are you sure I'm pretty sure
anyway seems like a thing I would want
to doy mark my waving I will oh you are
hey how' you do that I have nothing in
my inventory I'm clicking attack hey
Mark I'm gonna wave at you
[Laughter]
okay did you die I died I died with
before the fall ah damn it I'm the
greatest I punched you like twice and
you died yeah that some pretty beefy
punches I'm not I mean I waved at you
just I got too
close real life I've just been waving at
people and all the sudden they just
die that's your
superpower okay here we go all right I'm
back now I am the
greeter welcome to
Walmart okay all right so today I'm
drinking a new concoction I'm not sure
if it's even named it's UV blue
raspberry
and raspberry lemonade see it it should
be called The Mark we called it the big
fat lie and for a reason that Wade is g
to talk about soon it is not a lie it is
a giant lie it is the biggest lie you've
ever told me in your life I have a Texas
te
again ah and if you didn't know hel
Texas Tea is an ice is a Long Island ice
tea with a shot of whiskey yep yep Bob
six different shots in it I
believe
Bob uh uh can you hear me yeah yes what
are you drinking I uh High Life High
Life Again I'm living a high life yeah
okay now it's time for Wade to tell his
story because Bob set your
ometer ready this is a true story it's
not true I went to Putters with my
friend yesterday okay putter what to
where Putters what is
that bar grill restaurant is it like
Hooters but with like golfing themed
stuff no no miss the women with Hooters
well yeah that's golfers don't get women
that's true very true unless you're
Tiger Woods but all right so you're at
Putters there are no women it's kind
of you've already ruined my
story tell me about women there it's
just not Hooters kind of women oh okay
so it's LPGA Stars so you know that work
there now there's women that go there as
I about to tell you yeah oh okay here it
comes
because okay I got a model's phone
number International
model and I didn't do
anything it's a little it's a little
strategy I like to call penis fly
trap all right now that that is is that
the whole story that's a way dumbing
down let me let me read you the text he
sent me I will tell you the full story
once Mark reads the text once he he sent
me this at 11 in the morning yesterday
sorry I didn't make it to your show Bob
by the way Bob is in a band really good
band called you were going to come to my
show and you didn't for didn't not
getting a model's phone number no here I
got a super models number Super I drunk
and I'm not even super
model my Omer went off the
charts when I saw regular model I don't
know a super model though I'm sorry I
can see that it was a typo the standards
are a lot lower yeah that's very true
yeah I mean Bob you've seen
Wade
on wow I am not an ugly dude by any
means I am I'm like Tom Cruz and Brad
Pit you are thoroughly average my
friend well put is this oh my God I'm
dying why unless I can fly no I cannot
fly yeah we're we're on an island on top
of flat land accidentally jumped off the
edge it was an accident oh I see a
diamond how but anyway I went in to go
like to the bathroom and this girl was
sitting there with she was just in there
the sting at the table with her sister
and her
friend my first guess was that she was a
so that would make sense being
her being in the men's bathroom so she
wasn't in the men's bathroom she was at
a table you guys are totally twisting my
words no you're saying it you said all
that stuff
okay I will be more
specific I walked into the restaurant
from out on the patio where we were
sitting and watching the Reds game okay
and as I passed by the bar there was a
few tables to my left at one of the
tables there were four chairs three of
the chairs were occupied one by her one
by her sister and one by her friend
whenever I walked by she kind of like
smiled at me and I just kind of ignored
it a you son of a I just killed
Mark
again can I get ported back story going
on so going I come back out and I glance
over there again and her sister sees me
and like leans over the table and starts
Whispering into her ear and they both
start giggling so I just smiled and
moved
on came back in a little while later to
buy Taylor and his girlfriend a beer
they gave me money to do it and I was on
the outside and they were waiting on
food so I just volunteered to go in and
she kind of smiled at me so I smiled
back at her got the beers went back
outside came back in a third time time
to buy myself another beer I needed a
Yingling and whenever I came Yingling in
Kentucky we're this is in Milford
Cincinnati Kentuck no I had the setting
as Hooters which is in Kentucky no it's
not Hooters it's Putters in Milford oh
that's right the LPGA lesbian bar I
forgot oh my God you spot on there I
hate you
both so I come back in get the Yingling
and she comes over and all she says is I
think you're very cute and like blushes
majorly and real nervous and so I
started talking to her and I invited her
to come outside and she came and talked
to us or talked to me for a while talked
to us for a little bit then it was just
kind of her and I
talking and the end of the night she
said she didn't have her phone on her
but she wanted me to have her number so
she asked for my phone and she put her
number in there and sent a text from me
to make sure she got my
number and then she hugged me goodbye
like four times and was like you smell
really really
good sorry keep going I'm right there
with you she just got back from a
three-month stay in Italy where she was
modeling and she's going to China to
model soon and she works at a some
modeling agency in Columbus and where
she's at
today and tomorrow she's wanting to go
to a movie or
something uhhuh there's another girl I
started talking to yesterday oh yeah cuz
you're you're such a stud no because
because whenever whenever I find one I
always find two it's like there's either
nobody or else there's like two women
and I've got to make a choice uh-huh and
then if I neither one pan out I'm just
screwed
again so we'll see what happens but
zombie believes me right zombie doesn't
believe you he believes me I don't know
and I have no
opinion that means that he doesn't
believe you waade and he doesn't like
you either very very true you're such a
dick you know all you're doing is
creating more work for zombie when you
do that plus you're wasting all of our
time on start off the game kill
completely untrue story it is
true I swear by
it oh oh wait wait how old was she
18 oh I know a lot of really famous
models who are 18 she get her start in a
mall interational did she have to do an
audition in this guy's
basement I hate you all yeah okay did
you call the number or text the number
is it is it is it seven digits and an
area code God no it's it's not you know
all are seven digit area code so she
lives the same place we do oh okay yeah
cuz lots of girls from Milford just grew
up to be International models I didn't
you uh oh oh name the city where
International models are just born ow
Mark I thought you were trying not to
like one geographic location where it's
like have my baby and Guam because I
know she born model oh no I
didn't so what is the point of this oh
what I don't mean to yeah talk about
Minecraft or anything oh sorry yeah I
didn't even start my timer I don't know
how long we've been going like an hour
it feels like that story went on forever
I know right oh I did start my timer
never mind okay so I give you the you
guys are upset I give you the full
version you guys are upset there's just
no pleasing you it's just you see a
pattern yet
Wade yes no matter what I do know you're
a liar and we know your tricks I'm not
lying mhm that's the voice that a liar
uses when they're lying and that's why
yeah that's exactly what a liar would
say if you it's also the same thing a
person telling the truth would say no a
person telling the truth would tell a
story that made sense and sounded
realistic I you're never going to Reon a
good story is because it is totally hard
to believe here I'll give you I'll give
you the ultimate internet
altimative pix or it did not happen yeah
pretty much and he couldn't give me
picks so yeah I will get them I just met
her last night I've I'm hanging out with
her tomorrow right right sure well
you're goingon to have to lead off with
that because we're never going to
believe you
otherwise oh I didn't think I could
reach you
sorry definitely wasn't punching you
because I think you're a
liar oh I'm punching you because I don't
like you dick all right how are you
still hitting me okay stop everyone's
done we only it's not done we're only
going to make fun of way the entire
episode so hold on so we got new
objectives okay you know what I don't
even care you guys go ahead and make fun
of me I'm going to prove you all
wrong number one create a volcano number
two to the nether number three and my
favorite destroy Bob and that was voted
that was vot that was voted up on the
Facebook poll I wish that was number one
destroy Bob make a man Aon and Bosch it
into a volcano what what in the hell is
that that is exactly how it was spelled
it's a mannequin raccoon and we've got
to Chris BOS it into a volcano Manon m a
n i q French mannequin it's a
man does it surrender a lot and Bush and
Bush the White
Flag I got it no I got it did you get my
French joke yeah okay so I would but the
the scenario has changed because zombie
has provided us with this floating
island we're probably supposed to do
stuff I don't know I don't it looks kind
of like a big three-dimensional Mario
game if I oh
no ha
dick anyway um there's like iron there's
like iron and diamonds and coal beneath
us in great quantities so I guess we
should start digging we should probably
do do do mobs spawn on this is this like
not on this weird map that we can play
Survival on or it's like some flat land
wait I already have I'm in a fountain no
one
cares dick did I mention that are so
jealous I am not jealous we over not
jealous of your fake madeup story about
not
happen for the love of God zombie please
back me up he already he already weighed
in Zombie don't weigh in anymore don't
know and I don't have an opinion that's
it there you go that's
it yeah zombie knows how to play
politics whenever I prove you wrong
unlike right right all right I'm not
going to make political jokes this is
not the forum for I'm going to call you
tomorrow and you're going to come meet
me just so you can see me walking with
this girl if she is hot if she is I will
steal her from you I will I will ignore
the bro code you can try but I make this
look good you make nothing look good I
don't know if you know this but I'm kind
of the
man who out there agrees that Wade is
the man no one knows no one is seen me
chirp chirp chirp chirp oh that what's
that The Sound of Silence oh okay oh God
damn it there's already a crafting table
I'm only people here that can say
anything are you Bob and zombie and no
one in the world believes you yeah okay
to be fair as much as I love the fan
base we have watching right now they are
all going to be on Mark's side because
they're mark subscrib are you kidding me
they love me yeah they love Bob they
want you guys K interrupt him oh wait
yeah they want me to destroy Bob oh
whoops oh let not that
yet oh die you son of a wait your
jimmies are so rustled right now like
what what does that even mean your
jimmies is that like another jbjb thing
Mark no it's not a JJ thing my jimmies
are ruffled no jimmies are never mind my
jimmies are ruffled R by the way Mark
did you do any fact checking on the
jubjubs uh no did you find out that
that's not oh yeah well I L hey I found
TNT oh good this
TNT did you fall
yes there's Diamond down here but I
can't pick it cuz I don't have an iron I
don't have enough iron yet
oh wait where where are you digging Mark
I'm just digging straight down I'm
floating to my death again no one cares
Wade go talk to your supermodel
girlfriend about it oh my
God I should be talking to her right now
not you people yeah whatever oh
there's
Diamond hey Mark did you see that
there's Diamond Mark why are you
standing in blocks I'm not standing in
blocks on my
screen I think you're uh glitching there
Wade yeah
yeah we need Co I guess cuz Mark just
flew we need coal or wood I have some
wood yeah how do we get to the islands I
cob to make a a thing furnace yeah it's
already up by the crafting table okay I
don't know what we're doing I don't have
a we're playing Minecraft mark this is
Minecraft I'm making fun of Wade that's
right
no wait you told this story you started
this live all you have to do to get out
of this not a lie say to Mark and I I
apologize for being a dirty rotten liar
I am not lying and I will never to my
transgressions I am not and I will go
home alone tonight like I always do yeah
that's about it that sounds about
right are you actually going out with
this person who model tomorrow tomorrow
I'm going out with her did she say that
or do you think
that well watch out for her giant penis
and
um take a condom I found a block of why
would I need a condom shade a giant
penis one for each of you you know oh my
God would I need two condoms then you
dumbass hey he might be bad at math but
at least he's not a liar that's true
he's Asian he can't be bad at math oh oh
oh oh that was a compliment to
compliment oh God we don't do that here
Wade yes we do are all about having fun
and lifting each other up no my God I
hate you Bob Bob I met stand for
offensive jokes I Met My Doppelganger
yesterday a no joke he looked exactly
like me like I got a picture and
everything I'm going to put up on
Facebook I can't show you guys now but
seriously he looked exactly like me it
was weird he had the same mannerisms he
had the same ma the same laugh and
everything it was freaky as
hell I think you need to have a
conversation with your mom there
okay no the weird thing was he was um he
see I'm half Korean half German he was
half Chinese half Vietnamese which he
said equated to making him automatically
Korean because apparently that
combination of Asian turns you into
Korean there's a few different mixtures
you can use to make Korean yeah yeah
it's just like recipes in Minecraft you
know yeah it's mix and match and then
poof Korean hey Mark you're Korean yes
yes very true are you a fan of s sigh oh
gun Gangam Style yes I'm not a fan but
I'm a fan of that video oh
oh Style Style I've been thinking about
doing that as a reward just doing a
video where I I try to recreate the
entire video you should have you seen
show you that video didn't I yeah you
seen the uh chat chat roulette version
of Call Me Maybe yes I have you talking
about you should do a version of that
where you're doing gam Style on chat
roulette yeah yep in bikinis why would I
be wearing a bikini cuz that's the chat
roulette version oh like that one guy
the one dude who wears bikinis yeah I
know what you're talking about if anyone
out there hasn't seen it that would be a
huge gift for your fans I I don't know
but he's got a YouTube
channel he got real popular because of
that video Call Me Maybe guy yeah
something like
that anyway what are we doing I I don't
even know I don't have a pickaxe I've
got an four apples and some random
colored blocks I'm trying to get enough
iron to you know make it good pickaxe I
got some iron I have
like pick any of these I can't like
build up or pick up any of the um
Cobblestone
mhm it's not letting me pick it up for
some reason whoa what's that down there
there's something down there
creepers creepers OB you see Mark minion
hey here's a iron Mark I don't have I
don't have a axe why I'm not well you
can have my axe
yeah look creepers and my bow get down
there get down there get down
there
die okay anyway now back to Serious
Business oh yeah yeah create a okay we
got all this flat land out here because
we um we we we're going to build stuff
out there is how do we get back down to
the flat land without
dying
zombie zombie table zombie great I just
lost everything again zombie
water water oh water that would be great
aha H oh
no no my
[Laughter]
diamonds that's not
fair f what am I going to do with you
guys you going to love us
unconditionally okay now we got some
materials but that was boring so um
zombie can we have like
10 um we need a vol TNT no no not yet
later um we need we're going to make a
volcano so we need
like lava
lava ah making a volcano will be hard
man really we use for the base of the
volcano I don't know we make a glass
volcano a glass volcano you're an evil
genius but no I'm go out here where this
crowd of zombies is and then run so many
chest nothing in them okay I'm made a
volcano oh I
died hang on I got this hang on I got
this what why are there so many chests
that nothing in them ah it's a volcano
anyone seeing this is anyone seeing this
no one seeing it Mark what is that what
the
hell what is
that wait what is that what what is that
you're around it looks like a giant
chest know it's full of chests but
they're all
empty
what did you not hear me talking just
like no I did not I tune you out cuz I
just figur 90% of what comes out of your
mouth is lies oh my God mhm I sound
about right maybe 85 all your viewers
who support me and stand by me I will
reward one day whenever I show them and
you that I was telling the
truth uh no yes I will invite them to be
in a special video where I'm going to
have you tied to a chair and they can
torture you right they would like that
they would like that yes fan fan girls
especially I don't have a problem with
my fan girls my fan girls are great in
fact I'm going to spend 10 the next 10
minutes just talking dirty than them
okay you ready here it comes here comes
I'm gonna leave now hey baby I'll uh
take my shirt off zombie can I get
ported somewhere where Mark is not
what you can still hear my voice you
can't run away tell me that you love me
yeah
you anyway so okay I guess I won't do
that
sorry I got sorry I got your all your
hopes up and now it's not going to
happen anyway
volcano we need
to I already made a
spider hey I see glass up there what's
that die you son of a what's that
why do I see a glass plus sign up in the
sky anyone else seeing this where it's
over
there I see the
water look where I'm pointing
where are you even at
okay okay you can't see cuz you're you
see that see that see
that yeah way in the distance there yeah
yeah that thing over
there yeah do oh I'm walking right
toward all these stupid Monsters good
job okay build this is a volcano yes
that's my volc this a disgrace you're a
disgrace where's the volcano I uh over
here there's not one I haven't mocked
anyone it's marvelous oh it's Z proba
making it cuz Mark didn't do anything
useful over here I made a volcano what
are you guys doing we're making
volcanoes H I'm so sad that you didn't
die Wade so
sad I have no food I need a furnish to
cook some food no one cares eat it
raw
ow was that you no there's skeletons and
over here oh okay
hey creeper follow me hey creeper oh
this volcano is
glorious it's almost as bad as that
house that we made on one of the first
that house was beautiful you shut up
shittiest thing ever ow don't mess with
me oh you you died that was a live
stream I remember that that was a live
stream that was like the first Drunk
Minecraft I ever
did oh back never actually watched that
hey I got all W stuff hey cool actually
guys out there if you want to see the
very first Drunk Minecraft I ever did go
to my other channel marbl twitch it's on
there Drunk Minecraft is on
there and it up but we really
up there show your support for
Wade in the comments no one shows
support for Wade in show support for
Wade Wade got his imaginary
supermodel oh sweet Jesus I'm on fire
one day you will get to pose with me in
this model in a
photograph
Mark get that we have Mark on one of
those little setups where you throw like
a ball at the little Target and knocks
him in the water uhhuh yeah there's some
Diamond over here too where's all the
diamond coming
from zombie are you building this
volcano I'm not doing nothing I think
it's just erupting hear that hear that
he said he's not doing nothing which
means he is doing something that's
actually I'm over here how could I be
doing were you there for that
conversation last night Mark no wait
what no I don't think I had a debate
with someone last night about the
meaning of ain't doing nothing huh hey
can I get ported somewhere there I left
just after I met My
Doppelganger hey if I throw these steaks
into the lava will I'm die I'm going die
I'm going die I'm all right yes I win
I'm still chilling here so I guess I'll
see you in a moment oh okay oh what the
hell I get ported I've been here for
like 10 minutes wait you stay there you
stay there until you learn to tell the
truth I'm I've been telling the
truth I don't believe you for one second
No One Believes you waade oh no there's
lava God damn it no my stuff oh no my
stuff oh I'm going to die
I'm I say that was on purpose uh
because whoa the lava is like really
up on my
screen are you really not doing anything
to that zombie is that just happening I
don't think he yeah I'm not touching
it why am I spawning and being chased by
three creepers I told you the the The
Volcano I made was fantastic way just
didn't believe
me I'm going to blow it up with creepers
I saw you had like four
blocks you don't know you don't know the
intricacies of making a volcano man you
don't
know did did zombie give you like a
volcano spawner or something I don't
know but I'm seem to be on fire again
lava's just spawning around us zombie if
you're doing this I'm going to be so
pissed oh there's Enderman
everywhere
oh I'm I'm dying I'm
ding I need a port they're all chasing
Wade
this oh they're gone just act like
they're tall
models I'm going to climb back I'm going
to climb back up I'll see you guys later
I'm trying to make it to the top but I
keep burning
alive oh you oh up to the Mario Land it
looks like you're being ah
lava it looks like you're being ported
up by some star CP oh no I'm being
abducted by aliens no no zombie thank
you
no holy you guys should come up
here this volcano is Awesome from up
here I'm okay I'm coming I got to get
this on footage
man we're like stormchasers but oh my
God I fell out of the water oh no no oh
no oh I got back in s you got to poke
your head out of the water to see it
Mark got oh that is cool that's pretty
sweet I think that would be a check mark
on make a volcano yeah I would agree if
I had toan say not it's kind of like a
really weird volcano that oozes lava
from every direction but you know
whatever that's cool too you know hey
Bob get your ass out of the shot nope
Bob your ass is like right in the all
I'm getting is your ass thank you my
heart boxers yeah well actually I got
you I got a different texture pack so
you look a bit different you look like
Rambo I'm inside you mark really kind of
it's going to be sounds like the way it
normally is like oh Zinger from the liar
I'm
not I'm a man of integrity
right I am I am a man of Conant sorrow
so what I'm
dead good job there okay so I'm also
really sad that no one got my Brother
Where Art Thou reference I got it I it's
been so long since I watched that movie
holy
crap that actually a pretty thing why
wait
why you don't believe me why No One
Believes you does lava break Falls
zombie do you know uh oh I guess we're
going to find out yeah oh it does not
NOP it was only like one inch of lava
there so I'm going to try it again all
right just to be sure all right this's
this magical dust around us I don't know
I don't have
any away getting questions about the
color of my
clothing oh is is your model girlfriend
asking you
questions not right now oh it's the
other girl oh it's the it's your other
girlfriend I don't have no cuz you got
so many oh my God you guys you
guys at least we're not Liars
okay I'm not oh no I was going to jump I
was trying to pick a spot you dick that
was number three destroy Bob check does
that count as a win check that yeah Bob
wins that well if you'd have destroyed
yourself it would have counted as you
back in town loserville that's
true zie do you just like not Port
weight on
purpose I know I keep getting like insta
ported back and wait is just like man
I'm still at the spawn where are you
guys he just dies too much I think I
have and he's like dead again oh and
zombie joins the trash talking
yes wait you know what the problem is oh
boy I'm ready for what
uh we're all really mean people and
spiteful and you know we make fun of you
a lot and you just accept it apparently
I'm jealous of Wade because obviously he
has two International Super Monarch
model what I never only one of them is a
yeah only one one girl is a
teacher makes for very interesting it's
a whole different story than we were
told before the other what happened to
the there is a model
oh I I don't think I'm going to believe
you ever your first girlfriend was a
model too right well she got into
modeling at one point yeah oh yeah you
had a quote unquote model I've said that
before I think she took some glamour
shots at the mall if I recall yeah yeah
that sounds right you guys just can't
accept the fact that I can get whatever
I want Mark what are the other
objectives oh yeah there's tons shut up
um let's see make make a Mannequin and
push it into the volcano oh how do we
make a Mannequin I don't know I don't
know how you'd push it into I'm a
mannequin no wait no I'm not maybe make
it out of gravel put it right on the
edge of something and get sticky pistons
to push it all at once that might work
hey uh zombie can we get gravel and
sticky pistons sure where's that volcano
there it is okay and can you flatten out
this edge
here
sh all
right going to need a flat Edge right
over the
volcano let's see
here wait okay maybe we should be a
little kinder to Wade or not sticky
pistons normal Pistons that's right cuz
it needs to push it maybe we should be a
little kinder to
Wade I feel like there's a catch no what
the
hell z d away I spawned
in let's jump in the water oh what the
hell how are we down here what's going
on what is why is the volcano up here I
don't
know well this kind of makes it easier I
suppose what happened hang on
oh it was zombie making the volcano oh
no we have we have two volcanoes now
okay well I've got all this gravel and
I'm it's really
odd so you were saying you're going to
be nicer to me Mark yeah well I mean we
should why I
mean never
mind never mind nothing there's always a
catch with you no nothing nothing so are
we're being a nicer to way then is that
the decision yes that's no that's a
decision well tell us again about your
apparently real girlfriend Wade
I'm being nice don't laugh I'm not
dating I'm going out on a date tomorrow
oh well that's a whole different story
I'm gon to have trouble with this Mark I
met her last night just try oh last
night now it is it was always last night
the listeners will back me up on this
way just keeps changing the story
everything he says is different than
every other thing he says or
something where are you guys I uh to be
in the land of zombies and I'm in the
land of Truth
telling it's not a place holy I am
stuck on stuff and balancing in midair
is that good yeah it seems good oh damn
it ah God I can't get these sticky
pistons right I I I don't usually work
with or I don't usually work with
pistons so oh I see what we're doing
here yeah we're going to Bush it into
the lava is that what Bush would do bsh
bsh yes that's what bsh would do
the thing is is the the volcano that you
guys see here on the on this floating
island isn't real it was uh it's kind of
a graphical glitch if you relog it'll go
away and you'll see the flat area that
was supposed to be
prepared wait a minute hang on
disconnect and reconnect and it will
look perfect is it so unreal that I
won't die if I fall into the lava I'm
trying to fall into it it's not working
oh that's trippy wait but I'm dying why
am I dying I'm stuck actual volcano I'm
stuck I'm stuck oh there's lava
down there wait no there's not zombie
help hell is happen I'm stuck Rel log
zomie help what the is happening
I'm coming
mark I'm gonna do what the smart man
said I watch you suckers oh okay I
already logged out Lo in so now we just
have a big ass
thing
wrong
all right never mind you guys are idiots
you're an idiot what
why
why hey you're a
dick what oh no what the hell I'm being
killed by gravel I'm
falling there I am wait we're being
nicer to you it's going to let you tell
your girlfriend's story again yeah go
ahead wait go ahead I've already told it
no tell it again and this time I won't
say it's a lie yeah we're going to
totally believe
you well that didn't sound sincere Mark
no we are yeah why why do you need to
hear it again cuz I already heard a lie
now I want to hear some truth tell me
tell me the story again and it'll be
just truth this time that's how this
works
it's like you really think the viewers
want to hear the same story a second
time I don't think they wanted to hear
the first time but you
know I died I need more
pistons and everything
else zombie I don't know why you put up
with us we're like the
worst anything we're bad guests we're
bad at
Minecraft we're bad friends to each
other and to you yeah and especially to
Wade that guy's a
dick what
the I don't know I was just saying
stuff why does Wade get all this stuff
and not me cuz you didn't pick it up
oh oh no now I'm Wade I get left in the
spawn a that's so bad for you
Bob what level are you in
Diablo
some uh some I have a 37 Demon Hunter a
30 Witch Doctor a 30 wizard that's so
cute I don't think I have Barbarian I
haven't played that game in like two
months I forgot I had it you did well I
mean for you know it's kind of sucks but
it's getting better that patches soon
right that patch face the wrong
direction I thought that was going to
fix all kind of stuff it it kind of did
it's better now it's much better I think
mhm dude this is really satisfying
farming I'm going back and forth and
harvesting wheat but it instantly
reappears because I'm not allowed to
destroy stuff
here can't believe you don't that is the
saddest life I've ever heard in my
entire life I'm like that guy Icarus or
whatever Icarus the guy who made the
wings oh no it was his son that was
Icarus was Icarus the Sun or the father
no ikus ikus his wheel never stops
turning is that him one of those you
know Lessing tale grey what are you
trying to talk about the boulder one no
no there's a guy whose wheel never
stopped turning and he had to do
something it was annoying it was really
annoying it sound like the pain in the
ass there was the guy that had to keep
pushing the boulder up the hill and it
would always roll back down have to
start over again oh yeah well that was a
punishment from Zeus wasn't it I think
so yeah well they all those stories are
punishments of some kind man this got
really intellectual that so I was
on YouTube the other day watching some
gangang style remixes and
uh I don't have anything else to say
about that I I just wanted to lower the
level of discourse a little bit I've got
a model want to make fun of Wade some
more you were going to be nice and
believe me what happened why believe you
marks a lying sack of crap yeah that's
something like that oh you're trying to
kill me he I would
never you seem like
it wait you're such a dick I didn't even
say anything that time oh well then I
apologize for your death I will join you
oh man we're never going to do this what
are we even doing I don't know we're
trying to build gravel push into lava so
zombie we need some gravel and some
pistons and that's I've got tons of
gravel and pistons why do you have it
cuz you didn't pick it up well give me
some why is there a Golem Mark why is
there a Golem push it push it push it
into the volcano is that a manin does
that count as a mannequin it but it die
it back up you bushed it it did not die
can I go back up please wait but you
bushed it is there TNT in this don't B
me I was only considering it a little
bit don't Bo me
man okay dibs I got it thank you dick
Goodbye Oh oh oh no what was
that what was that zombie what's going
on I I didn't do that I think you
did we all just exploded I'm pretty sure
that was like uh some debris from the
volcano what what no you're bullshitting
us my
how did it hit was punishment
for killing me and not believing me I
didn't do anything I was just standing
still those volcanoes erupt and they
send junk flying and remember this this
floating island has like traces of TNT
built into it oh well that all seems PL
plausible please tell me you both
haven't been ported already yeah we're
back why am I still
here Wade you know why you're still
there times why Wade why oh I got the
water oh oh I'm alive oh what now oh yes
I got the water too suck it
wait wait the dick wait the douche oh
this house is totally like
surrounded by lava on all
sides man there there's a Golem it's
just sitting there is it like
unconscious or something no it's just it
fell in the lava just then it died it
died it just walked into lava and killed
itself God damn it why Wade why you me
you pushed me off
a and you live
there we go how did you hit me from
there and I couldn't hit you isn't there
a way to make our respawn Point like
different no please that would make your
life so much easier ZB I don't
care to do that doesn't seem to be
working oh no that's a creep oh no it's
a zombie
okay holy why is everything behind
you exploding Mark it's a volcano
it's meant to be hey I found a
creeper well good for
you okay what are we doing we destroyed
Bob create a volcano I'm pretty sure
destroying Bob has already happened
pretty thoroughly yeah okay believe Wade
we made oh I found the chest Castle
believe Wade is not on this on this list
at all I've already told them they will
be rewarded for believing me okay all
right I'm de serious I believe that you
got a number from a girl
who was who did modeling at some
point you don't believe she's still a
model that she was just modeling in
Italy like a week ago no I do not
believe that in the least not even a
little
bit she may have told you that but you
even you shouldn't believe that I I saw
her I believe
it I need to see pictures of this girl
or it didn't happen or it didn't happen
preferably naked you know can you ever
bent over a little bit yeah yeah let me
just hey by the way remember my name
that's a good first state thing have you
tried that Wade have you yeah it single
I
died oh Mark you're an idiot sh Bob I'll
have you killed why is this guy talking
about drinking blood you pretty much
just kill me all the time anyway so
probably a vampire I have no fear
anymore okay oh no Lava hey I'm not on
fire even though I touch lava H okay
actually we're getting close to the end
of this episode we didn't do anything we
didn't what we built a volcano well we
didn't but zombie know zombie did and
then the volcano built itself you guys
tried to tear down my self-esteem but
failed because I got a model who's into
me no you don't keep telling yourself
that
yeah you sleep you will all see I could
get a model I am on fire you can get a
hand model and not in the NBA Jams way
the oh you wait you don't think that I
could get a model do
you admit it I could very easily why
could why why don't you believe that I
could you're so
ugly just kidding I'm just kid no I'm
not kidding I'm not kidding not not ugly
at
all that's why it's
funny I will to put a picture of you up
on my Facebook and I'm going to have a
poll that says his way ugly it's going
to be dominated you know what you should
do is you should put a picture of way up
with Forever Alone face I should that
would be perfect that would be you're
going to find like the worst picture of
me you like really trash and get a
picture of you from that actually
there's a picture of me on my Tumblr if
everyone goes to that Tumblr website tum
what's Tumblr his fan girl thing that's
it's not the whole website isn't
dedicated to me oh Mark stalker's
Tumblr hey they're not stalkers not yet
are there any pictures of me cuz there
shouldn't be no there's none actually no
we're out of time we're out of time we
ran we ran this episode right we're it
got do this has been Markiplier on Drunk
Minecraft with Wade and Bob been Wade
and
Bob Wade is a liar everyone knows this I
am not a liar agree with me and you
shall be rewarded thank you every AG you
what my reward right com you you've
already called me a liar in the comments
ow I exploded WR in the comments that
Wade is a giant liar and agree with us
that he does not have a supermodel I
never said okay I did say I changed it I
corrected itday you're a flip-flopper
then you're not a liar you're a flip
flopper yeah anyway I was drunk and I
admitted my St mistake right away oh
yeah we'll see you in the next video
byebye